south africa is calling out thousands of
troops to stop violent protests after
the arrest of the country's
former president the violence including
looting and arson is now in its sixth
day
more than 70 people have been killed and
more than 1200 others have been arrested
deborah patra shows us a growing effort
to stand up to the rioters deborah good
morning to you
good morning about 25 000 troops report
for duty today
it's the biggest deployments in south
africa's first democratic election
in 1994 looters brazenly saunter down
public roads carrying their bounty it's
red cars in the road
they've looted everything in this area
soldiers went door to door hunting for
stolen goods
it was an easy haul it appears just
about
everyone was guilty of stealing
something
i'm surrounded by piles of stolen goods
that police and soldiers have retrieved
from looters there's everything here
from food
to clothing even cooking pots
years of distrust in an often powerless
police force
has seen armed groups take the law into
their own hands
that included carrying out vigilante
justice
with devastating consequences when a
15-year-old boy
was gunned down in the crossfire the
anger by former president jacob zuma's
supporters
over his jailing for contempt of court
has dragged
up something far more explosive a
burning resentment over decades of
inequality poverty and hunger fueled by
pandemic hardships
as the streets of south africa smolder
it's now hoped that boots on the ground
will put out the flames of insurrection
while the looting appears to be leedless
police are investigating 12
ring leaders whom they believe
instigated the initial violence
that was deborah patta reporting from
south africa